Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Nous avons tous entendu parler du succès
des grandes équipes de foot,
de leurs joueurs talentueux,
de leur cohésion,
de leur détermination
à remporter des victoires.
Ce soir, je vais vous parler
d’une équipe bien différente.
Une équipe qui n’évolue pas
sur un terrain de foot,
mais ici, dans nos rues,
dans nos quartiers, à Bruxelles.
Une équipe dont le succès ne devrait pas
se mesurer par le nombre de trophées,
mais par le bien-être de ses joueurs.
Cette équipe, c'est nous.
C’est notre équipe de Bruxellois
et de Bruxelloises.
Comme dans un match, chaque joueur
a une place déterminante
pour la réussite collective.
Comme dans un match,
nos entreprises, notre région tout entière
dépend de chaque membre
pour atteindre les sommets
du succès économique.
Mais il manque souvent un élément :
le bien-être des joueurs.
Imaginez un instant
qu’un entraîneur néglige
la santé de ses joueurs.
Que se passerait-il ?
Les blessures s’accumuleraient.
La fatigue deviendrait insoutenable.
Et l'équipe terminerait par s'effondrer.
J’ai moi-même fait partie
d’une équipe de foot.
Pour s’entraîner à marquer des buts,
on a besoin de plusieurs éléments :
d’un terrain,
d’entraînements, d’un staff,
et de sens.
Oui, marquer des buts, c’est important.
Cependant, si ça se fait au détriment
de notre santé et de notre environnement,
à quoi bon ?
Il y a trois ans,
il y a trois ans, j’ai fait un
arrêt sur images de ma vie.
Il y avait beaucoup de succès, beaucoup
de réussite, mais très peu de sens.
Le succès de notre équipe
de Bruxellois et de Bruxelloises
ne peut pas uniquement se mesurer
au nombre de buts atteints
ou à notre PIB.
Il existe cependant
un modèle économique alternatif
qu’on appelle la well being économie.
L’Islande, la Finlande,
l’Écosse, la Nouvelle-Zélande,
considèrent le bien-être
de leur population et l’environnement
pour mesurer leur réussite.
Petite anecdote :
des femmes étaient à la tête de ces pays
lorsqu’il y a eu ces changements.
Je vais vous donner quelques chiffres.
En Belgique,
il y a un demi-million de personnes
qui sont en situation d’invalidité.
Un demi-million de personnes
en situation d’invalidité
parmi les employés, les indépendants
et les chercheurs d’emploi.
Cela coûte à nos pouvoirs publics
21 milliardsd'euros par an.
21 milliardsd’euros par an.
Entre 2018 et 2021,
le nombre de cas de burn-out
a augmenté de 66 %.
Le bien-être des Belges
diminue depuis 2019.
Quels sont les indicateurs qu’on utilise
pour mesurer le bien-être
des Belges, de nous, des Bruxellois ?
Notre santé, notre niveau de vie,
notre éducation,
notre travail et notre vie en communauté.
Les études montrent
deux choses préoccupantes.
La diminution du bien-être
est due à la détérioration
de l’état de santé des Belges.
Et la baisse de ce bien-être
ne touche pas uniquement
la population actuelle,
mais elle va toucher
les générations futures.
Alors il est primordial
de prendre en compte le bien-être
dans le plan de relance économique.
Imaginez des ateliers en communauté
pour développer le développement
personnel de nos citoyens.
Regardons autour de nous.
Que ce soit
dans les grandes équipes sportives
ou que ce soit dans les entreprises,
les meilleures équipes ont compris
quelque chose de fondamental :
le développement personnel
est aussi important
que le développement professionnel
et il mérite d’être considéré
avec le même niveau de priorité.
En mettant l’accent
sur le développement personnel,
on porte une attention toute
particulière à la santé mentale.
Imaginez participer à des ateliers
qui vous permettent
d’être dans l’instant présent,
d’apprendre à respirer,
qui vous permettent
d’améliorer votre sommeil.
de mieux vous alimenter.
C'est ce qu'on voudrait mettre en place.
Les dirigeants [inaudible] bruxellois
sont pionniers dans l’utilisation de
ce qu’on appelle les chèques sociaux.
Que sont les chèques sociaux ?
En fait, les chèques sociaux,
ce sont des chèques
qu’on donne
à une certaine population-cible
afin de les orienter
vers une dépense ciblée.
Je vais vous donner quelques exemples.
Par exemple, les employés
utilisent les chèques-repas
pour améliorer leur alimentation.
Ils utilisent également les éco-chèques
pour consommer de manière plus durable.
Vous, les ménages,
vous utilisez les titres-services
pour rémunérer de manière plus équitable
vos aides ménagères.
Il existe aussi d’autres exemples
très inspirants en Belgique,
par exemple les chèques-sports
de la Ville de Liège,
pour inciter les jeunes
à faire plus de sport.
Ou les Pass Wallonia,
utilisés par la Wallonie
afin de relancer le tourisme
après la pandémie.
Il existe aussi des chèques
utilisés pour la santé.
Par exemple, au Texas,
on accorde des chèques
à des femmes luttant avec leur santé
mentale pendant ou après leur grossesse.
Dans le Dakota, on utilise aussi
un programme qui octroie des chèques
à des agriculteurs et à des éleveurs
ayant fait face à des problèmes
de situation mentale après la pandémie.
Alors oui, mettons en place des ateliers
pour développer le bien-être
de nos Bruxellois.
Je vais inviter le staff santé de notre
équipe de Bruxellois à créer ces chèques.
J’ai moi-même créé une entreprise
dont la mission est de développer
le potentiel de chaque individu.
Mais le travail est immense.
Je suis prête à accompagner
le staff santé
dans le soutien pour la santé mentale
de nos Belges.
Il y a trois ans, j'étais devenue
spectatrice de ma vie.
Une vie qui n’avait plus beaucoup de sens
et qui n’avait plus beaucoup de bien-être.
Depuis, quotidiennement,
j’utilise des outils
qui me permettent d'être ici ce soir.
Si je vous dis ça,
c’est qu’on peut tous être vulnérable
et que c’est dans cette vulnérabilité
qu’on trouvera notre force.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)